♪
>> Tucker: HAPPY NEW YEAR.
AMERICA IS STILL A GREAT
COUNTRY.
THE BEST IN THE WORLD.
BUT IT'S ALSO FRAGILE.
WEALTH AND POWER ARE
CONCENTRATED IN FEWER HANDS
THAN AT ANY TIME IN OUR
HISTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WE WOULD IT ARE
SHORTSIGHTED AND UNWISE.
SOME OF THEM ACTIVELY
THAT DOESN'T MEAN DISASTER
IS COMING.
BUT IT COULD.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN 2018.
GOOD MOMENT TO REVIEW THE
THINGS WE DO KNOW FOR SURE.
HERE'S A MARSHALL LIST OF
THEM.
WARS ARE ALMOST NEVER MAKE
COUNTRIES RICHER OR HAPPIER.
READING THE INTERNET ALL DAY
DOES NOT MAKE YOU SMARTER.
SENDING MORE TEXT AND EMAILS
DOES NOT MAKE YOU
PRODUCTIVE.
HAVE YOU AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT
TO SAY WHAT YOU THINK IS
FRIENDSHIP IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN POLITICS SO ARE SPORTS,
ATTACKING PEOPLE BECAUSE OF
THEIR SKIN COLOR IS WRONG.
THIS IS ALWAYS TRUE, NO
MATTER WHAT THE COLOR IS.
THE BEGINNING OF WISDOM IS
UNDERSTANDING HOW LITTLE YOU
CAN CONTROL.
GENDER IS NOT A SOCIAL
CONSTRUCT.
IT A BIOLOGICAL REALITY.
THEY ARE NOT INTERCHANGE
JINGLE BELL.
PRETENDING OTHERWISE IS
ABSURD.
IMPOSSIBLE.
FAMILIES FAIL AND A SOCIETY
COLLAPSE.
ANIMALS ARE CLOSER TO HUMANS
THAN WE THINK.
AND PEOPLE ARE CLOSER TO
ANIMALS.
NO MATTER HOW MANY PUBLIC
IT COMES DOWN TO IT, YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOURSELF AND
YOUR FAMILY.
BEST TO KNOW THAT AHEAD OF
TIME.
THE ONLY IMMUTABLE LAW IS
THE LAW OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
NEW AND IMPROVED ELECTRONIC
DEVICES RARELY IMPROVE YOUR
LIFE.
OFTEN THEY ENSLAVE YOU.
NO TEXT MESSAGE OR SOCIAL
MEDIA POST IS EVER WORTH
INTERRUPT AGO MEAL WITH
PEOPLE YOU LOVE.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS ONE
DUTY, SECURING THE
WELL-BEING OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
RELATIVELY FEW PEOPLE WHO
WORK FOR THE GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT
CHARITY BEGINS AT HOME.
BEFORE YOU SEND A CHECK TO
FIGHT MALARIA IN CONGO OR
SPONSOR A SYRIAN REFUGEE TO
COME TO MINNEAPOLIS.
LIVING ON THE STREET OR
HELP.
LAWS CHANGE, CUSTOMS AND
BELIEFS CHANGE.
A LOT CHANGES, HUMAN NATURE
DOES NOT CHANGE.
ANY FOOD THAT MAKES YOUR
MOUTH WATER LIKELY BAD FOR
YOU.
IN THE END, ALL THAT REALLY
COUNTS IS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OTHER PEOPLE NO MATTER HOW
SUCCESSFUL YOU ARE, IF YOUR
KIDS HATE YOU, YOU HAVE
FAILED.
HISTORY HAPPENED WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT.
AND FINALLY YOU WANT TO MAKE
THE WORLD BETTER?